foreign
how many times we've broken up and gone
back together I think it's three part of
me feels like I'm sometimes splitting
two sometimes things are really great
and I go this is awesome I'm really
enjoying life and we're out doing stuff
and things are glass and other times I'm
just what have I gotten myself into is
your girlfriend nuts
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney's show
show about your mental health and your
families and boundaries and
relationships and marriage whatever's
going on your kids
summertime whatever you got
here's my promise I'll walk alongside
you if you're new to Our Gang I'm so
glad that you're here this is a real
show about real people going through
tough stuff trying to figure out what to
do next
tired
of living the same old way and ready for
something new and then looking up and
going whoa I don't have a road map so my
promise is I'll tell you the truth and
if I don't know the answer I'm gonna say
I don't know and I'm gonna sit with you
while we try to figure out what the next
right move is I'm honored to walk
alongside you and I'm grateful for
everybody who calls if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
and um please it's such a gift to your
neighbors
cost you nothing but like 10 seconds of
your time if you'll just take a quick
quick second to like this show subscribe
to the show on YouTube if that's what
you're picking us up or to like or
subscribe to the show on podcast leave a
five-star review as such it's a blessing
listen if you're the one walking up and
down your street you're like oh my
neighbors are nuts
simply leaving a review helps out your
neighbors because it kicks the show up
into the algorithms and it puts the show
right in front of their face and maybe
they can start
making better choices in their life that
would be pretty cool for all of us right
all right let's go out to Michigan to
the great city of Lansing and talk to
Brother John what's up John with the
greatest name ever how we doing good how
are you doing thanks for having me you
got it man thanks for thanks for uh
giving me a buzz what's up
so I'm uh 26 years old and I'm just
wondering how do I navigate my
relationship with my parents who are in
the process of separating oh man what
happened
well I mean I'll try to give you the
story let me know if I start to Ramble
On too much but essentially my parents
have been married about 30 years
um and there's some things I don't know
all the details of because you know I
was a kid when a lot of this happened
but I guess about 20 years ago
um there was an issue where my mom had
made some untrue statements about you
know some domestic situation it had gone
to court we I remembered living separate
you know with my mom away from my dad
for a time then they got back together
after things kind of settled
um and my mom had apologized to my dad
about it but hasn't ever really made
kind of like a I guess my dad hadn't
felt like she's made a kind of a public
acknowledgment that he isn't you know
this monster or this person who she had
said that he was and there's just been
issues kind of stemming from that where
he's never gotten over that past hurt
um and she's kind of you know just kind
of put it behind her as oh you know I
apologize to you like it's done and then
things kind of basically surfaced you
know again this past fall
um
and my mom ended up kind of leaving the
house in December around the time of her
birthday when she would usually go on a
trip uh down south to stay with uh her
stepmom down there
um but she ended up staying down there
for like 12 weeks
um and part of it was she was saying
that she was helping you know uh this
relative move because they were in the
process of moving they're a little bit
elderly
um but the whole time you know she was
saying oh you know your dad he told me
that I had to leave the house
um and then I met welcome back where you
know then if I asked my dad he's like no
you know I miss her I wanted to come
home like I can't get a hold of her
um and then finally she moved back into
you know moved back to the to Michigan
um in like March but ended up moving
into
um a condo with a relative of hers that
was sick
let me hop in here did she no you're
good man you're dude I'm the chief
Rambler man you can't touch me I'm the
goat at rambling so you're good
um I appreciate you you welcomed me
through that story quick point of
clarification
did your
mom accused your dad of some sort of
domestic violence again
or uh no has never happened again
this summer this fall
um
I think it was around the anniversary of
like when did it happen
so what was the accusation
it seems to be a dark shadow over your
parents marriage
um it I don't it's hard for me to say
because it's like I've never heard them
both talk about it to me together where
it's like they're both speaking about it
together so it's hard to say because if
there could always be like a he said she
said but so um I'm assuming the courts
didn't put your dad in jail so I'm
assuming the court said it with him
yeah something along those lines were
but the the exact station was something
about either that he had beat her or had
done something to the kids or that it
wasn't a safe situation but that you
know that wasn't the case I have no
memory of any situation like that so as
as one of your parents actually filed on
the other one
no they haven't but it's like
it's kind of like
it could be any moment they're kind of
you know yeah there could also be
another 20 years because they were going
to separate when she made all these
accusations against him and he stuck it
out
so here's here's what you've got and I
hate to do this not in person because
um it can be pretty callous okay is it
cool if I just didn't just kind of cut
to the chase
yeah go ahead okay
um it sounds like
and again I know there's always two
sides to every story right but it sounds
like your mom did something
that was pretty awful to your old man
back in the day
and maybe it was 80 20 maybe it was 90
10 but then it sounds like your dad is
acting like a four-year-old for the last
20 years or last 15 years of
not wanting to move on not able to move
on and when I say move on not just
forgive and forget that's what I'm
talking about I'm talking about if
you're gonna if you're out of your
marriage leave your marriage
um give your yourself and your family
opportunity to heal or if you're all in
you got to be all in back in it just
seems like both of your parents this has
just been a weird dynamic and so I I I I
have no evidence from the story you just
laid out that they're actually going to
get divorced
sounds like yet another move that
somebody's putting on somebody or
somebody and maybe they will maybe get
divorced tomorrow
um I've got a couple so so I say all
that what's your response to that
um
I I've definitely seen that because I
know back you know my daddy used to say
that he was gonna that they were gonna
probably separate once you know my
little sister like went to college when
she was out of the house um and then
that didn't happen but I guess what what
recently developed is when she came back
into the area but still is not moving
into the house that relative that she
was helping take care of ended up
passing and now my mom's trying to buy
her condo from my cousin to then live in
this new condo and that that's what's
making me think that it's like it's
become she's been practicing living on
her own for the last three or four five
months
yeah okay
um have you sat down individually with
each parent and talked to him
um I've been able to talk with him on
the phone individually
um
and I guess what's hard is you know my
mom is you know I love her and she's
great but she can just be kind of a
manipulative and emotional and like if
you try to you know give your honest
opinion of like hey you know this isn't
the right move like I don't think you
should you know be taking out a mortgage
to buy this condo it's not you know it's
not you know you're acting you know a
little bit too you know irrationally you
know she she you know she can't take
that feedback It all becomes a personal
attack of like is she asking for that
feedback
what was that is she asking for that
yes and no okay because the other day
you know because my my another kind of
dynamic is my wife works for her she
owns like a small business oh geez
um and then that's a you know there's a
blurred boundary there of you know
family versus employer
um yeah it's definitely Robin Thicke
Blurred lives there brother
yeah and she calls my wife you know kind
of upset almost crying saying you know I
feel like you know people are talking
behind my back but they won't just tell
me you know they are of course they're
thinking all right so I'm gonna jump in
here here's yeah go ahead uh you're
gonna have to grow up real quick okay
and so I'm gonna rattle some of these
off if one or two of them just sounds
stupid or doesn't make sense or might
not work in your family push back okay
step number one your wife's gonna have
to get a new job
Point Blank period if you want to keep
your marriage intact you want to have
some sort of relationship with your mom
Downstream she's gonna have to decide to
get a new job and I absolutely
understand the complexity of what that
will look like both interpersonally and
professionally all that
number two you are gonna have to make
space in your soul
to be surprised by how sad you are
if they the divorce actually goes
through
especially young adults you know 20 to
I can't tell you how many I've sat with
who are just stunned by how sad they are
the parents split up like they're
grown-ups they got their own family
their own house
but there was always this anchor they
were anchored into even if their parents
marriage was a disaster
there's always this this tiny little
fairy of a of a uh fantasy that things
are going to work themselves back out
there's a finality to I just bought a
house I divorce you and as a kid no
matter how old you are it's a
it's an unmooring thing the floor kind
of comes out from underneath you so I
want you to be expecting that don't
fight it don't run from it but when you
get real sad be real sad that's okay
it's not nothing to be ashamed of you're
not broken you're not weird
I would if I were you so I'm just all
I'm doing is projecting myself into your
situation 26 I'm married my wife works
for my mom I've also been talking to my
dad on the phone I would set aside a
weekend and I would go visit each parent
individually and what here's what I
would do I would lay out my
participation in this moving forward
here's what that means dad
mom says she's buying a house that y'all
looks like y'all are moving on I here's
gonna be my role in this I'm gonna love
you you're my dad and I'm gonna love her
she's my mom I'm not picking sides
and I'm gonna cut off any conversation
that gets negative about the other
parent I'm just not going to participate
in that
and I want you to spend some time with
you and your wife coming up with
whatever those boundaries are gonna be
the more you can get on the front end of
that and let everybody know yourself
included what you will and will not do
um the better off you're gonna be able
to find out where they are and the
better off you're going to be as this
thing unravels and gets messy and silly
so there's something about just saying
hey this is gonna I'm gonna cut off
negative talk and your impulse is going
to be to rescue your mom rescue your dad
you can't be their best friend you can't
be their therapist you can't be their
Pastor doing all this mess you can say I
love you have you called your friends
I love you so much I hate that you're
good you're hurting like this
um have you gone to see a counselor but
you can't be their person as hard as
that is okay and then here's the last
one
I want you and no second to last one I
want you and your wife to preemptively
Imagine Holidays
preemptively imagine birthdays
and I want you all to come up with a set
of ground rules that you will dictate to
your parents not the other way around
because all of this you get you get
divorced in September it becomes
finalized at Christmas
Mom and Dad have very clear pictures in
the head of what Christmas is going to
look like and both you and your wife are
involved in both of those pictures
and that's not going to be possible
and so I want you all to preemptively
have that discussion and it will break
your heart to do it it'll feel it will
feel surreal
but I want you and your wife to say okay
this is what Thanksgiving will look like
for us and Mom and Dad chose to separate
they chose to to be by themselves on the
holidays it's not our job to fix that
loneliness but here's what we can do
we can do the morning here in the
afternoon here we can just pick one this
year and the next year we'll pick one
because they chose to separate not us
it's not your job to make their holiday
fantasies come true and their birthday
fantasies and when y'all start having
kids all
guys we're having one birthday party
y'all can both be adults and come to or
y'all can decide amongst yourself who's
coming or not we're not going to play
dad's house in Mom's house and Grandma's
I'm not gonna do that whatever y'all
decide to do okay here's the last thing
tell your mom and dad that you love them
every single time you talk to them
every time even if you're pissed off and
you're mad and you think they act like
children tell them you love them every
step of the way because you're going to
need some sort of tether back to family
in reality all right I just do a ton at
you what do you think
um I mean
that is a lot but I think there's a lot
of good things to pull from that and I
think you know establishing boundaries
is going to be really important I guess
my one last thing regarding that is just
I feel like I so badly want to try to
help don't don't don't counselors give
feedback when they're asking for
feedback nope nope nope nope nope
um because they're going to drag you
into the nerd word is they're going to
triangulate you they're gonna you're
gonna become the fulcrum of their
relationship
because you're the oldest boy you're the
26 year old you've been helping in your
your quote unquote making it and weirdly
they mom gave your wife a job you owe us
to that's why I say your wife's gotta
gotta decouple from that she's gotta
she's got to go a different route
you have to withdraw from some of that
entanglement so that you can put up
clear boundaries and not have those
things held over your head
you're gonna get dragged into it and
that's why I said You're Gonna Wanna
rescue your mom and your dad from the
choices they have made
and you can't do it
can't do it what does that sound like in
real life
honey I'm so your mom calls you and
she's crying I can't believe your dad
did this did this
um
I'm so so sorry that you're heartbroken
it breaks my heart
I'm not going to talk about Dad on this
phone call I've already talked to you
about that not gonna talk about Dad
but I will tell you I love you and I'm
so so sorry that you're heartbroken have
you called so and so and you fill in the
blank
and that's going to be you putting up
really firm strong boundaries because
you can't rescue them out of this
is that gonna be hard for you
it'd be hard for me it'd be real hard
for me yeah it's going to be hard
especially because it's going to be an
adjustment because I feel like I've been
someone who likes to I mean I'm someone
who likes to give counsel and advice and
say Hey you know this isn't you know the
smartest decision right now or hey can
you you know can I tell you can I tell
you what my guess is my guess is you've
been parenting both of them for most of
your life
and my guess is you have been the voice
of reason for them for most of your life
and my promise to you is that is not
your job
and unfortunately it never has been
let me rephrase that it has been your
whole life unfortunately it should not
have been
and so the problem with divorce is it's
not never it's never between just two
people it ricochets through a family a
ricochets through a family system
and the Dynamics that have existed for 5
10 15 20 30 years like in your case even
unhealthy ones everything is blown up
and so everyone around this situation
even when it divorces Justified and it's
right and it's the right thing it's
still painful to everybody
and there's family systems that have to
create new Dynamics and new avenues and
New Paths out in the woods because man
it's just different now things are
different so yeah you've been the fixer
and the helper and the parent quite
honestly probably for your whole life
and you're gonna have to find esteem in
other places so instead of solving every
problem with a magic wand or breaking
your own back to solve their problems
you're gonna have to shift to I can't
solve this one y'all chose this but I'll
sit with you and I love you
not going to talk about mom not going to
talk about Dad not going to give you
advice and wisdom but I love you and I'm
grateful for you thank you so much for
the call Brother John holler back if I
can help in any way we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back hey before we move
on to the next call
um during the break
I had a good conversation with Jenna and
Nathan so Nathan you you uh Nathan's the
guy who runs all the screens he's the
YouTube guru
um so hey man you you um you experienced
this tell me about it
yeah so I was 28 I believe when my
parents divorced and it is like it
doesn't matter how old you are it still
definitely sucks no matter what stage in
life you were in did that surprise you
how much it
how how unsettling it was
um because by 28 you already had 14 kids
and right uh we had just had our third
at that point and so I think that though
for us in the stage that we were at in
life it was really difficult because it
felt like we lost two grandparents at
the same time because my mom had to go
into survival mode and my dad ended up
um moving further away and ended up in a
different state so we lost the support
at a time when we really could have used
it in life so that became difficult and
that but that was
every situation is different and there's
a lot of different Dynamics at play that
that really affect you and your story
how did you
um manage
being both angry
at one parent more than the other versus
Still Loving them because they're my
parents
um
there is definitely a season where I had
to just take a break because it just
make me too angry and upset to
um
be around particularly my dad he was the
one that had filed so it was easier for
me to blame him in hindsight a place
where I came to was that eventually I
saw my mom land in a much happier place
in life and so now I'm more in a place
of like hey
um I'm grateful that it happened because
she her life was improved in the long
haul it was a hard season of life for
her and to see her go through that and
she's my mom and I'm her son and I
protect her and want to care about her
but to see
um to be happy for her to her to Linda
that place was really beneficial but it
took time so your meta lesson is divorce
is great in the long term right good job
Nate excuse me just kidding Jenna what
about you yeah so for me I was about
sixth grade when my parents got divorced
and I'm the middle child so I've got an
older brother who is in high school so
when my parents got divorced he was able
to go off and do his own things and then
I have a younger sister who she really
didn't know what was going on at the
time so for me I was that middle ground
for my parents where when I'd go back
and forth between their houses your mom
did this and your dad said this and so
for me it was struggling but I was with
my mom more of the time we only saw my
dad every other weekend so in my mind I
always took her side and that I think
that strained my relationship with my
dad a little bit and it's hard because
you're also in middle school you're
figuring out who you are at that time so
it definitely shaped me a lot of who I
am now but it's so yeah like you said
any age you struggle with it like my
sister at the time didn't really know
what was going on but now she can talk
about it and process what happened for
her and same thing with my brother he we
all just coped in different ways so if
if you are
parents getting divorced
please be cognizant of your kids
because they just get dragged it's like
chaining them to the back of a truck and
taking off down the highway they just
get bounced along behind the truck and
um
they get put in hard and tough positions
and for parents know this your kids
cannot rescue you from this hurt it's
not their job this is a choice that you
made it's a choice you made and it's a
choice you got to sit with and the
choice you got to wrestle with and
choice you got to live with your kids
can love you and they will love you
but they can't they can't rescue you
from the hurt of divorced man it's tough
thank you thank you guys I appreciate
that can I say one more thing of course
um the
in my experience it's better if you feel
like your marriage is on a path towards
divorce and you know that's happening
don't just stick it out for the kids for
a long period of time because either way
it's going to hurt them and it's better
to get it over with and get to that
place where you're both in both land on
your feet and able to continue life in a
better place than rather uh prolong this
long agonizing relationship that causes
more pain and suffering for your kids so
when you see the place where your mom
landed
is there a part of you that wishes that
like they had just called it 20 years
before instead of playing married
uh yeah basically I mean uh the place
where my family was at the time wasn't
that wasn't really possible yeah but
um yeah I think that's the advice that
I've come to of like don't just prolong
it because of kids especially if they're
really little and I don't and I'm for a
marriage don't get me wrong or I'm
trying to I'm like do everything that
you can to bring healing and restore and
all that great stuff but uh if it is
inevitable don't prolong the pain that
you're gonna put on your kids and feel
guilt and waiting for that especially if
they're younger when they're younger and
they're a bundle of nerves they're not
going to remember that and they remember
chaos yeah yeah so they'll feel they'll
have the
um the implicit memories of that but
they will be able to grow from that
earlier than later in life when they're
really established in the relationship
of knowing that Mom and Dad are together
that's the smartest video camera guy
you're ever gonna see in the world ever
way to go man
um thanks guys I appreciate you Jenna
Nate let's go out to my hometown and H
tone gostros and talk to Sarah what's up
Sarah
hey Dr John it's so great to talk to you
it's super great talk to you man how are
we doing
I'm good I'm hiding in my closet from my
kids that's right
um that's what moms do in the summer
oh Kelly just raised both hands and said
preach sister what's up oh see I know
I'm not alone here okay oh you're
totally alone I'm just kidding what's up
what's up no so my question was I guess
I phrased it how do I better handle my
anxiety and my stress in the summertime
and so to give you a little back you
know background I am a wife and a mom of
three active boys
uh eight almost 10 and 12.
it's Rowdy over here I bet so
so summertime for like my teacher self
are you a teacher
oh yes I meant to add that to the end
yes I am a teacher what years
um well I'm in elementary but I'm I
jumped into special ed this past year
okay
so can I just say thank you for your
service
you've been deployed and you're back so
thank you God Almighty that's a tough
road
so when did when was school out
um we got out about a week ago
um actually it was both right before
right before Memorial Day
um so I'm kind of a week into like okay
finding our group as a family no no
there's no Groove yet
okay okay so I'm trying to give myself
Grace mom gets two weeks to recover
like at least two weeks
that'd be awesome my boys are like a
thousand miles an hour I know I'll I'll
walk you through how to deal with them
but mom is all of this starts so my
guess is that anxiety is a couple of
things number one your body's fried it's
cooked you're exhausted I've been a
teacher you're done you get done and you
collapse and then some idiot in your
life's like oh my gosh it's so great to
get Summers off and it's like bro I'm in
recovery like I'm not this isn't off
I've been working at 6 a.m to 8 P.M for
the last anyway
so number one your body is trying to get
your attention to be like we can go no
more we can go no more number two
probably you tell me if I'm wrong your
husband is a fully grasp
severity of everything
and he's um just business as usual
he is no he's amazing he's wonderful he
carries helps around the house like
carries the load with me
um but he is okay so a new piece of this
puzzle is he just started working from
home about a year and a half ago oh fart
in a box on a stick yikes that's a lot
of dudes in your house
yeah it's a frat house
there's pee everywhere oh geez
so I think like in March literally March
or April I'll have a day where i'm like
I need to talk to you and he's like is
it is it are you getting nervous again
about summer I'm like yes like the
groceries I've been to the grocery store
every day like the kids eat constantly I
try to force the schedule and they they
just it just feels like chaos sometimes
and I feel like as a teacher
I'm used to and they are as well being
kids in school is like routine structure
like this is every minute of our day is
calculated and then when we have
summertime unstructured play is so
important but it's also like the Devil's
Playground like they go nuts when
there's this freedom and we we do plan
things and we have friends we go hang
out with or we'll go somewhere but we're
not spending tons of money and we're
trying to live within our means really
well
um and I have I'm jumping in
because if you were here I would ask you
permission if it was cool just give you
a hug for a second no you do me a huge
favor
yeah I want you to take as deeper breath
as humanly possible I don't want you to
hold it for an awkwardly long count of
five okay
like as deep as you can ready one two
suck in as much air as you can
and hold it one
two
three four
five and when you exhale I want you to
pull your shoulders down as low as they
will go
okay now you just sit there for a second
okay number one
you are not a bad mom for wanting space
between your boys and your husband
got it
yeah the next time you tell yourself
that I want you to
say hey Sarah I talked to this YouTube
guy he said that's not true
okay
you're not a bad mom for want to break
you're not a bad teacher because you
have three knuckleheaded boys and you're
quote unquote supposed to be the expert
on all this stuff and you don't know
what day it is
what happens is you get in this Loop
that well I must be terrible at my job
but it must be terrible at home and I
must be terrible at my wife and what
kind of mom does he want to be around
her kids I finally get time off and you
get in this death spiral and you end up
in your closet on the phone with a
podcaster
right
yeah yeah okay unstructured play is
incredibly important for kids
and
so are ridiculously firm boundaries
so creating time and space Here's what
that looks like
it looks like you calling a family
meeting with the boys
and saying prefacing it with this is a
grown-up conversation
and they will go and they'll look at
each other's side-eyed and kind of get
all tough and and you tell them stand up
tall stand up straight it's a grown-up
conversation
and don't get all Wiggly waggly
and then you tell them beginning
tomorrow
mom
is off limits until 10 A.M
hmm
bomb's off limits
what you're going to give them is an
Incredible Gift of watching their mom
rest
and recharge and recoup
and they're going to take this lesson
into their marriages
they're going to take this lesson with
their girlfriends they're going to take
this lesson into the workplace
when they have exhausted pregnant moms
working for them who are also incredible
at their jobs
so you're I'm talking about total
life-changing Legacy change by simply
telling your boys mom's off limits until
this time
and you you've heard of your teachers
you've heard of conscious discipline
just the framework so one of the
cornerstones of that framework one of
the one of the Seven Pillars or whatever
you call it is choices
I found out once that my wife was
actually doing this to me and I didn't
even know it she's a teaching Guru but
here is your options for breakfast they
get two choices and they get to own the
choice
here is the options for between the time
of 7 30 and 10.
you will go outside but also you won't
leave the yard so here's two or three
things you can do in that time
if one of you violates this all three of
you fill in the blank here's the choice
you'll have made and here's the
consequencer accountability
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to slowly give these boys some
autonomy within some really strong
fenced walls
and they're going to feel like they're
pulling one over on Mom they're going to
practice autonomy they're also going to
be safe they're also going to break
stuff but it's going to be in a place
that you design things to be broken in
and Mom is going to wake up slow and
have coffee and read and journal and
stare off into space and put her feet up
outside on the front porch
see what I'm saying
yeah I was thinking about like
um you must do these things like in the
morning time you get to pick
when you say must they go to war
when you say here's your two choices
they feel like they win
right it's this it's what my wife did
she's like
um we can go to
um Mexican food or pizza and I'm like
I'm the man of this house we're having
Mexican food that's what I'm talking
about and she got what she wanted you
see what he kept saying so we're not the
moment you start going to must and you
have to
the moment those boys and you
desperately want them to Buck that
system because one day their government
is going to tell them you must and
they're going to go do we like and
that's that's kind of that's the kind of
men you want to raise
and so we're gonna give them practice on
how to give Mom space
give them practice on how to honor mom
and dad and they're gonna test they're
gonna run their little 8 and 10 and 12
year old heads up against these
boundaries and see if they hold
and with a smile on your face you'll say
Hey you chose to interrupt me between
when I woke up in 10 a.m so you just
chose for absolutely no screen time
today at all none zero I hope tomorrow
you don't make that choice
yeah and they will get that message real
real quick when Mom's firm
yeah I feel like I've been really rigid
before where I'm like okay we're doing
this this and this and this and this
like with the schedule of our day but
you see how you see you're you're
telling them what they're going to be
doing instead of inviting them getting
the choice that's right okay and it's it
is Magic
inviting them along for the ride and the
lessons Downstream are beneficial now
I'm gonna tell you this right now
there's going to be some morons on the
YouTube channel who come those boys need
to be told what whoever says that is
stupid they're dumb they're dumb it's
dumb it's not good for them short term
it's not God for good for the middle
term it's not good for them long term
because you're you are in the process of
raising men you're not in the process of
curating a summer vacation for an eight
and a 10 and 12 year old
also you and your husband
who's I in no way am I saying he's a bad
guy not even close he's probably an
amazing guy I trust you that he is
I didn't know what I didn't know
and it wasn't until the school year was
over that my wife started saying okay
here's what I've just been through
here's what I need the next 30 days to
look like that I got a picture of her
world
and so it's really easy for me as
husband a guy who loves my wife who's
involved and engaged with my kids
to just wake up June 1 and it's business
as usual
and I've got a wife suffering from PTSD
who's who is also now full-time
stay-at-home mom and not fully recovered
yet so it's important for you and your
husband to go okay
what is June going to look like what's
July going to look like what are we
aiming towards
what is camps who's going to drive who's
going to pick up how does this impact
your work from home all of those things
let's just go sit down and say okay
let's dream together what the things can
actually look like
what's our picture for the summer
because the picture might be your
husband's had a pretty quiet house to
work from home
and now he's got three Maniacs in there
and a wife who is listens to a lot of
murder podcasts and at some point
they're not going to find your kid's
body because you know what to do you see
what I'm saying like he's gonna expect
but his picture is business as usual
your picture is God I need some help and
so all both of those are great you just
gotta sit down and and navigate that
together
yeah yeah
can I give you one more thing
yeah that time until 10 A.M
if you use that time until and I and by
the way I just picked that number
arbitrarily it could be nine o'clock it
could be noon I don't care what it is
that's for you and your family but there
has to be some protected time for Mom
that your boys get to see Mom is
honoring her mental health and her
physical health and our family by taking
putting her oxygen mask on first they've
got to see that and it's got to be
sacred time
yeah you can go ahead
I'm one of those um
weirdos that goes to work out really
early fantastic
so they see me come home you know they
know where I was but then they're like
Mom I want this mom wants that and my
day just goes it's like I just yeah and
you wake up and it's 2 45 p.m and you
just start yelling inside I just I
crazy
crazy I don't like that it's okay but
but I want you to take ownership of the
craze it's not these rambunctious little
boy's fault that they're rambunctious
little boys thank God they are
it's the structure and the balance and
not balance I hate that word it's the
structure and the boundaries inside that
house
so I'm going to tell you something
that's really hard but I'm telling you
because I love you
the crazy that you're feeling is crazy
crazy you are allowing to happen
and so what I'm telling you is to just
take ownership of the day and you gotta
have your husband's buy-in on this so
I'm glad that here you say I get up at
5am
it's real easy to fall into the Trap of
just do nothing in that Holy sacred time
and I want you to be intentional about
that time whether it's exercise whether
it's calling your mom whether it's
writing letters whether it's going to
have going to work out at 5am and then
meeting a friend for breakfast at 6 30.
that'd be awesome
yeah it would be
put that on your calendar and let your
kids know yeah mom has her special
breakfast with on Tuesdays and Thursdays
yeah I have a hard time relaxing my
husband will type that out I'm like he's
on the couch after we've cleaned up or
done something you know after dinner or
whatever and he just sits and I'm like
how do you just sit he's like it's good
for you you should try it okay can I ask
you a real hard question that's gonna be
kind of a left turn
oh sure
wait let me try to ask this in a polite
way
where did the I'll I'll ask it how I
asked a caller on a previous show where
did that ticker tape that runs below
you know when you watch the news that
little thing has a stock market
underneath it just running and running
yeah yes underneath the the movie that
is the life of my friend Sarah from
H-Town my hometown
your ticker tape just runs and says
you suck at all of this you're not good
at any of this you're not good at any of
this
where does that come from
I don't I don't know if I really say it
to myself I know but your body
experiences it and here's how I know
okay because you
are unable to prop your feet up and let
your knuckleheaded boys run around
because you think I'm quote unquote
supposed to be fill in the blank
the supposed to be and the shoulds Never
Stop in your heart and mind
yeah sheds not a great word no and it
dominates your life
yeah I don't know I feel like
um
I
I just I don't know I growing up I had I
have amazing parents and my dad was
always traveling he's a pilot and so my
mom was just
she she was doing everything while dad
was gone you know and I think I just
maybe it's just like my vision of what
being a mom is it's like you're non-stop
you're serving your family you're like
not you know and yeah go go go go okay
you just did like a Year's worth of
therapy in 30 seconds
here's your magic here's your magic
moment are you ready
sure yeah I want you to take your
husband out for a half day just half day
pay for the babysitter whatever you got
to do
don't leave those three boys because
they'll they'll burn your house down and
you know that yeah yeah I want you to
take your husband out
and I want you to explore this one
question
husband who I love who's amazing what is
your picture of a wife and mom
not what do I think it is because both
of you can talk and you're going to use
the same words but you're gonna have
very different pictures
and I want you to paint a picture of
what you think the perfect mom is the
perfect wife is the perfect housekeeper
is whatever words you want to throw in
there
I'm almost guarantee you that your
husband is going to be like I that lady
scares me
and I think you nailed it I think your
body's running an old script that it
picked up from an awesome mom that you
had
you got to do this you gotta do this you
got to do this you gotta do this but the
message underneath that you got to's is
you're nothing if you don't
and I think that message would stun you
if you were honest about it and it would
stun your husband because he loves you
and he knows you're incredible
I know you're incredible
so let's build a life
I say this all the time let's build a
non-anxious life in our home starting
with Mom puts her oxygen mask on first
mom takes care of mom so that she can
lean in and be a maniac with these boys
and of course we're gonna go to the pool
of course we're gonna go to Camp of
course we're gonna go to the zoo
whatever other junkie got going on we're
going to the Astros game or whatever
but every day starts with Mom honoring
mom and mom having Sabbath and rest and
peace and whoo and Mom and Dad building
a life together that's sustainable
throughout the summer so that we can go
back in to be a teacher in the fall
so proud of you I'm so grateful for you
stay on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of own your past change your future
it's got some ex some steps on how to
build this life I'm talking about
and I can't wait man I wish it was in
the fall because I got my new book
coming out can't we I need to get it get
you a copy of it when it's out
um but it's not out yet
um just to lay out the steps here but
you are on the way Sarah thank you for
being brave we'll be right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here look
you made it halfway through the year
congratulations and maybe you started
this year being a little bit more
intentional about mindfulness and then
the culture convinced you that you gotta
run harder snap into a Slim Jim and you
find yourself back on social media
watching nonsense influencers sharing
their life hacks for doing more and more
and more listen my friends
don't sacrifice sleep at the altar of
productivity hustling is well and good
working hard accomplishing things is
great but burnout is very real and
burnout is when your body just says I'm
out
and as a society we are exhausted and
when you're running on empty you got to
remember to recharge your body sleep is
the number one way to recharge your
physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
cloud and right now dream Cloud
mattresses are running an awesome offer
exclusively for our listeners 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings it's time to start
prioritizing your sleep go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney that's dreamcloudsleep.com
with code John deloney
all right we're back let's go to
Northern Oklahoma or as some call it
Canada let's talk to Matthew what's up
Matthew
hey Dr John how you doing today great
how about you man
I'm doing phenomenal this is unreal it's
great to be here thank you so much man
what's up how can I help
that guy let's let's jump into the let's
just jump right onto into it here so
really here's the quick setup I mean I
listen to you almost every day while I'm
at work as long as well as the Rams are
showing and you've really helped me in a
lot of areas of my life and I just I see
how many people you help
um so hey I thought you know maybe you
can help me too so let's bring it on
thank you thank you man what's up you
betcha so my goal really with this call
is really just to try and get some
answers and solve solve some of the
problems here
um that I may be facing personally and
and specifically in my relationship so
I'm looking to solve problems in my
relationship
um you know how do I know I'm dating the
right person and how do I bridge this
gap between my myself and my partner in
in this relationship so what happened
that precipitated this call
so I mean here's the setup right so I'm
28 years old my partner's a bit older
than me she's 31. we've been dating on
and off here really for the last six
years and and I've lost track now how
many times we've broken up and gone back
together I think it's three
um fast forward into today we we
recently bought a house together with
living together here for the last six
months and and really a part of me feels
like I'm sometimes just just splint too
sometimes things are really great and I
go you know wow this is this is awesome
I'm really enjoying life and we're out
doing stuff and and things are a blast
and other times I'm just you know I
catch myself just thinking what have I
gotten myself into and I can start you
know catching myself gearing up to ways
to get out of this and it's really just
disoriented me and it's exhausting and
I'm and I'm trying to I really I really
want things to work I think overall and
and it's just we've been having these
we'll have dumb arguments really about
nothing that I just come home and
they'll just leave me wiped out so can I
ask you some real direct direct like
just cut to the chase questions
I'll do it absolutely if I did this in
person it would feel insulting so I'm
just gonna go at it okay
that's fine let's let's jump into it is
your girlfriend nuts
and hey it only works if you tell the
truth when you get home does she start
crap with you and start fights with you
and tell you that you're stupid and
you're dumb and you don't do this right
like what are the what's the nature of
these fights no I'll tell you so it's
it's I don't I don't think she's nuts
and really how do you define knots
anyways it's oh I've got some pretty
clear I work with Kelly I I know very
just kidding uh very clear what do you
think oh yeah I wrote down some examples
because I figured this was going to come
up so here's an example like I've got a
great career I'm doing really well in
life and as an athlete and I'll come
home
um from a busy day at work um and you
know I get home and I just want to throw
some I'll throw some clothes on the on
the bedroom floor and go jump in the
shower then I'm a guy sometimes I forget
about them and then I'll go off and do
some other things make a smoothie go
outside sit on my patio and you know
then it's hey you know what you got to
clean these clothes up do this or or you
know the last fight we just had I'll
give you another example is we'll be
fighting about a utility bill for
example and it's like she's like hey the
the bill costs fifty dollars more this
month why is that I'm just my kind of
thought with it is hey it's a utility
bill it's just money it's fifty dollars
like money
money is not the issue here where you
know it's not it's not a problem but
so here's the issue I can tell you right
now okay twofold
number one have you heard me talk about
pictures and words here
pictures and words have you heard me
talk about that on my show
uh no okay the great William Glasser
said that he could fix most marriage
issues in one to two sessions
and I rolled my eyes and he said 99 I
made that number up a significant
percentage of marriage issues
is a mismatch between pictures and words
what do I mean
when you and your wife or you and your
girlfriend bought this house
you both use the word let's buy a house
together you both said let's make a home
in her picture of home
is straight out of Pinterest
and she grew up in a house where and I'm
making something up here so I may be way
off but just go with me
where
her mom got beat up for not having a
clean house or her mom cleaned the house
and she saw her dad look at her mom and
say thank you so much for loving me so
much I'm really grateful or maybe her
dad sucked and threw crap all over the
place and she heard her mom whisper I
wish she just showed me enough respect
to clean up his stupid underwear
and then that is wrapped into her
picture of home forget the words picture
and your picture of a home
looks like a place where you can after
being on all day every day you can just
drop your shoulders throw your stuff on
the floor kick your feet up because ah
I'm here
you both love each other
you both want to make a great home you
both just have a different picture of
what that looks like
and so you find yourself in these weird
fights about clothes and about TV
channels and about forty dollars extra
on a light bill
it has nothing to do with it at all it
has to do with your wife is desperately
trying to create this picture of this
home she has in her head and this life
she has in her head and you both are
using the same words the joke I use when
I talk about this from stage is my wife
comes out and says hey let's go on a
really hot hot date this weekend it's
going to be smoke show
and I start thinking what hotel we're
going to end up at in what city and what
we're going to be wearing and for how
long and for her hot date is the Burrito
Barn has tacos for a dollar on this
Friday night
I love tacos and she likes romantic
Rendezvous but both of us end up mad
when we finally realize that we're not
doing the other thing that the other
person thought has nothing to do with
what we want or what we intention has to
do with how we discuss what's this world
we're creating together I'm also going
to give you this picture and this is
just from the data okay it's just from
research this isn't me preaching at you
it's hard to play house and also anchor
into a stable relationship that's been
off and on for six years
and so some of the frenetic energy you
feel in the house is a body your wife's
body and your body trying to regulate
the realities of living together which
is hard
and also
trying to live together and do hard
things without being fully anchored in
the ground
because when you buy a house together
but you're not married you don't you
don't legally bind this thing together
the idea is but I could leave
nah but I could leave
and that plays havoc on each other so
I'm going to tell you my wife and I
dated five years we broke up five times
twice it was a forever breakup
and we'll celebrate 21 years this summer
of being married
here's what it came down to
largely me
saying I'm gonna go all in
I'm gonna Choose You
as the woman I'm going to commit the
rest of my life to and that choice is
going to be every day and it's not out
of a movie it's not the notebook wasn't
true like Titanic wasn't true I wish it
was man but it wasn't
and I'm going to commit to you and I've
almost blown it up a couple of times
over 21 years it's not gonna be perfect
and it's gonna be messy but I choose you
and that means I'm not going to say
stupid stuff like uh you know I'm just a
guy so I don't pick up my underwear pick
up your underwear
I'm saying
you sitting down and telling her hey
here's our financial picture
let's do this together so that if a
light bill comes in 40 bucks over
we smile about it it's it doesn't wreck
our life I grew up in a home Matt that
um
forty dollars an un on like a 40 bill
that came in unexpectedly
took away took food off our table was
was tragic
right so I am it's extra attuned to that
even now
it just kind of wired into me so my wife
has to constantly John we have enough
we're good we're good we're good I can
look at the numbers I can see the
numbers I know we're good intellectually
my body still says that water bill is
like whatever it is right so I just
threw a lot at you
what do you think
I I agree with that and I I you know
like I said I I've heard you say I'm a
long time listener and I've I've heard
you say you know you got to be all in
and and I completely agree with that I
think or any relationship to the review
who do you have to be all in and I think
the where I'm running into problem and
where I'm running out of steam is is
when we come home and and I've you know
I've said sorry yeah I want this I want
to be all in with you and I like it and
I I'll come home and it'll just be a
fight it'll be something and then I can
just I can figure myself gearing up and
I'm going oh my God and I I'm running
out of this theme of of just commitment
to you because we just have to keep
dealing with what keeps going on here
and it's it's driving me crazy and I
would I do agree with that yeah I'm
happy to clean up the clothes yeah you
know life is about negotiations and I'm
all good with that and I've been trying
to do a better job with that but listen
don't don't negotiate the details yet
negotiate the pictures
and that starts with this question over
a breakfast and I think at some point
you all been together 60 years so I
think calling this out
we bought a house together we are all
but married
I want to spend the rest of my life with
you and I can't continue to live in a
home where there's fights that escalate
like these do all the time
foreign
and so here's what the question I want
to ask you honey who I love
what kind of home do we want to build
because we get to choose that
what do we want our life to look like
and where this is scary is she might say
I want it to look like this and you know
in your soul I can't do that or I don't
have any interest in that
and I also have friends who dated five
six seven years that ended up breaking
up and marrying other people that's
brutal and it's devastating it's hard
but it was right
but you can only get there if you're
willing to own reality to choose reality
I love you we have a home together we've
been together for half more than half a
decade and I can't take another month of
these fights
are you willing to build a new life with
me
and really that's you dude is being as
vulnerable as possible because she can
look at you and say no
that's scary right
yeah
scary so let me ask you this what if I
told you just break up with her dude be
done
does that give you peace just be done
man you put in six years it's not
working call it
foreign
I can breathe a little bit here
and Another Part Of Me would be
absolutely crushed because I know that I
do how much I feel how much I love this
woman and um yeah how I feel about her
I think that's the question to explore
that you've got to be honest with
yourself about
great I also don't believe and
I know some of the the marriage
Instagram gurus are gonna come out of
the woods on me for this but I don't
believe that it's a hundred I just knew
without a shadow of it I dude I don't
know a lot of people who had No
Reservations I don't know those people
but I know that when it works it's when
people say despite the reservations
despite the
come what may I'll be right here
the commitment is on me
yeah
that's scary and hard man
sir yeah are you in or out
well I mean are you in or out in or out
do it say it yeah yeah
exactly I want to be in I I want to be
in and I really want to make this work
and I do want this because I see us
building a really great life together
okay and and but but stuff has to change
that's where I'm at with it I love it
stuff has to change so I want you I want
you to write this those things down and
I want you to spend as little time on
the details as possible
and when you write these down this is
critical for you and anybody listening
to this
when you sit down and have take her to
breakfast and it's gonna be a two or
three hour Affair and some little
Canadian Bistro I don't even know if
that's a thing that I just made that up
here's here's the conversation it has to
be all about you
what do I mean by that if you sit down
and say I just come home and I drop my
clothes and you're doing this and you're
doing this and you're doing this
then she's got to go to war with you
but if you sit down and say
I have a picture of my home that is warm
and safe
and I'm I'm out at work all the time and
I come home and I just drop my shoulders
and then I feel like I disappoint you
and you get upset that I've left
underwear and I'm tired of being I'm
tired of feeling like a disappointment
in my own home
or the water bill comes in it's 40 more
expensive than we thought it was going
to be I know how much money we make you
know how much money we make and I feel
like I'm failing you because I haven't
provided a safe home for my my future
wife
you see how you aren't attacking you are
saying here's how I feel
that's much more inviting so I want you
to take the time to write down on a
piece of paper
how you're feeling which is like ill
gross
take the things that are pissing you off
take the things that make you mad and
there's I know there's a list of things
that you are courteous enough not to
have aired your dirty laundry on a
podcast that's fine
but I want you to be honest about those
things and don't go start throwing darts
at this at this time together I want you
to say here's how this here's how I'm
impacted by this
here's what makes me nervous here's what
makes me excited about moving forward
here are some things you do that make
the house feel like this
we gotta we gotta own reality we gotta
choose reality start from there
I actually have some pretty high hopes
for this relationship because I think
you love this girl I think she probably
loves you I think six years is a long
time to put two people in a cage and be
like make good choices
that you start just gnawing each other's
tail off
have this conversation hey please do me
a huge favor I'm kind of invested in
this now reach out and let me know how
that how that breakfast goes how that
time together goes I want to hear how it
goes and we'll be rooting for you every
step of the way my brother we'll be
right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back and as you wrap up
today's show I want to tell you I'm so
grateful for everybody listening so
grateful for everybody listening a great
song from the 80s from the one hit
wonders Madness song's called our house
and it goes like this
father wears his Sunday best Mothers
tired she needs a rest the kids are
playing up downstairs sisters sighing in
her sleep Brothers got a date to keep he
can't hang around our house
in the middle of our street our house
it has a crowd there's always something
happening and it's usually quite loud
our mom she's so house proud never ever
slows her down and a mess is not allowed
our house
in the middle of our street
I've never taken the time to read the
lyrics to this this is basically like a
like a dude just
writing about what happened today and
saying hey guys you want to make an
international hit and they're all like
all right let's do it
way to go Madness way to go I love you
guys bye